I got a long list of them I got a long
list of them uh for me you know a part
of it is you know what people are doing
to the greatest country in the world
that changed my life I'm gonna do my
part with the fight against them the
establishment in a big way those that
are targeting kids to confuse kids I got
four of them now it's a very formidable
opponent
what do you do with the lies on both
sides related to all this because look I
supported Trump I've interviewed Trump I
like Trump in a lot of ways and I will
vote for him if he's running against the
Democrat so my cards are on the table
the lies about Florida the lies about
coven I I could go on and on the lies
about fauci and all that stuff like
what do you do with that you're someone
that cares about truth you've mentioned
your faith several times like what do
you do about that because I think a lot
of people are struggling with that right
now they're seeing the lies and they're
having trouble kind of connecting that
to the rest of their life or their ethos
and and I understand that okay
um here's what I've learned no matter
the more you study history and whether
you like this or not you can rip this
argument apart as much as you want some
of the best people that fought for our
freedom were complicated human beings
period misunderstood complicated complex
personalities weird upbringing difficult
to be around strange people weird habits
weird obsessions strange vices just
purely complex people who saved the
world these are very weird people
then you can look at the people that
were proper people the people you like
the people that all the things you and I
value that what a sweet man what is this
what are that they don't have the dog
fight I'm sorry history doesn't favor
Perfection the people that go out there
and are willing to do the fight they're
not going to fit the profile that
everybody is looking for is Donald Trump
one of the most complicated complex
strange people you support them one day
next day like what are you talking about
did she ask you a basic question do you
know the difference can a man be a woman
can a woman just say why are you taking
five seconds to answer the question just
say it and but you don't know why he's
doing that is he playing with her is he
playing with the audience did he just
have a meeting 30 minutes before making
Kelly with his five people that are
trying to figure out a way to give a new
messaging because he's losing three
percent of the vote in a you don't know
what he's thinking but what you do know
is everything he's doing is intentional
he doesn't wink he's not a Winger he is
a guy that will say wait you see what
we're gonna do wait till you see wait to
see him wait to see it's kind of like a
salesperson wait do you see wait do you
see part of that is a Visionary driver
Future Truth totally get that but he is
also a guy that's kind of watching
everything and sizing everything up and
he's taking risk here then he adjusts
that message didn't work let me change
this or that message work is pissing off
the right people let me poke on this guy
but to me we're not going to get who
we're like aspiring to get this perfect
candidate it's just not going to happen
so since uh Trump has chosen an awful
lot of enemies I really like what we've
done with this shot can we go to pbd's
one shot one shot look at that we get
the book right in there that's very nice
choose your enemies wisely who are your
enemies these days I got a long list of
them I got a long list of them uh for me
you know a part of it is
um you know what people are doing to the
greatest country in the world that
changed my life I'm going to do my part
with the fight against them the
establishment in a big way those that
are targeting kids to confuse kids I got
for them now it's a very formidable
opponent the people that are how much of
that is happening I mean you're here in
Florida I'm sure your kids are going to
grade schools and all that but is it is
it like just stuck in the culture that
that it even has to come up for your
kids who are obviously insulated I'm
still running an insurance company with
40 in 49 states and we got 46 000 agents
that 15 000 of them are active right now
so I get all the news from all these
different states on what's going on they
call me and I'm talking to them so we
have people on the ground that are
experiencing this in California and you
know Riverside then you got Oakbrook
Chicago then you got you know Dallas
even some schools in Dallas like wait
this has happened in some parts of
Dallas yes and you've got you know New
York or Calverton Maryland or you know
all these other areas they're going
through it right so you're hearing it so
I'm not okay with that part and then for
me I think in the media space I got a
lot of enemies in the media space and
you know some of these enemies are
making big mistakes some of them you're
just seeing that they're in it for only
money they haven't made money yet they
made a few million but they've not made
money money so they're kind of like
looking for their first 100 million or
first 200 million and I understand that
you've got to go through making that
first million then first 10 then first
100 and then maybe you go add the
additional zero and two additional zeros
then you have the ESG Community these
Larry Fink these Wall Street State guard
Vanguard Soros he's giving the fund back
to his son and he's running it now I
think his name is Alex 38 39 years old
and he's very close to Bill Gates
by the way good move for Gavin he's
gonna need that guy's money and you know
this you know uh open Society Foundation
that Soros has given 32 billion dollars
to the last 30 years or so that that's a
very powerful non-profit organization
open Society you got to watch these guys
so then you got Hollywood and what
they're doing so we got to find a way to
make movies to compete against Hollywood
and what they got going on but there's a
lot of enemies but to me
you know you have to be you have to be
very intentional on choosing the right
enemies the wrong enemies bring out the
worst in you for example Let me Give an
example women
who chose the feminist movement they
chose The Wrong Enemy men are not the
enemy what are you doing how many 65
year olds today who are single with no
kids are coming out saying I made the
biggest mistake of my life
what did they do they chose The Wrong
Enemy men were never the enemy
Christians Muslims and Jews
they're choosing each other as the enemy
none of you guys know for a fact you've
not died and come back you've never met
Jesus or Abraham or Muhammad you pray to
it we all pray to it so what did the
enemies that we all see today
values and principles that are being
fought would you realize that Christians
are thinking Muslims are the enemy
Muslims are thinking Christians are
they're not the enemy it's the
establishment of globalists that are
pinning against each other we're
choosing the wrong enemy
we have completely most of us missed the
mark on choosing the wrong enemy and
it's destroyed people's lives
we've lost Decades of Our Lives some
years some Decades of some their entire
life is gone with so you know the reason
why I wrote this book was more for
people to realize
that we all make the mistake you know
sometimes you're like I'm gonna do it to
prove that guy wrong that guy doesn't
bring out the best in you but the other
guy does
but the other thing does or the other
institution does so for us we got enough
of the right enemies right now where the
driver what we wanted again God willing
if God keeps me around for 40 years oh
my God and we're healthy and what does
that get you feel like it's either 84.
84 yeah got the number for you I'll go
to 100 but it's a he dictates I'm going
to do my part I'm trying to take care of
my health right now the last few years
I've lost four inches on my waist
there's a few things I did four years
ago in July stopped drinking soda I
don't drink soda at all so
and then you know a few months ago I
don't eat breakfast except for Sundays
and breakfast my favorite meal I don't
do breakfast anymore I just skip
breakfast six days a week so I'm at a
weight where it's 235 238 is my weight
at my height I was at 258 260 which you
wouldn't tell if I'm 260 you know
because I'm a little bit taller so it's
kind of gonna stretch but at 235 237 I'm
good I have the right people around me
that my trying to take care of my health
and all that stuff but at the same time
look God can also say you think too much
of yourself man you know who do you
think you are man you do you think we
need you or you know you're going to be
okay come up here and have him go clean
the cloud who do you think you are and
I'm okay with that but how much is that
worry you though because I will tell you
this is something that I've been
thinking about lately like again I I
have the things that I want right now
and I've had a thought lately that I've
never had before which is
I have like it seems to me like the the
shoe has to drop at some point like if
you have the things that you want the
life you're living the life you're
supposed to be living like doesn't that
doesn't last for very long right like
something always is gonna happen whether
you know a death in the family uh yeah
whatever it might be I've been thinking
about my dad dying since I was 18 years
old when I joined the army because my
biggest goal in life when I was six when
my teacher asked me what do you want to
be when you grow up I said I want to be
a dad because I wanted to be him great
father very good father I wouldn't be
wine right now if it wasn't for him he
lives with me now I'm the happiest now
that he's in my house my kids see him my
dream was for my kids to me I met him I
met him I met him yeah I didn't realize
he was living there yeah my dream was
for my kids to know this man because I
never met his father right so I wanted I
wanted them to have an experience with
this but you know but I know I'm gonna
get a phone call one day you know we're
we're going out to a nice uh my son's
birthday is coming up so we're going to
the Yankee Stadium it's going to be the
first time we're going as Yankees you
know we'll wrap with this yeah first
time we're going there so we're gonna go
there and take him to the game and then
go to you know the the the Jets game
Patriots game and all the stuff that
we're doing he can't go he just told me
yesterday I can't go I said what do you
mean you can't go right we're just
talking about this today he's trying to
convince me to convince my dad he said I
can't go he says we go I'm not feeling
good he was in a hospital for five days
a couple weeks ago he's 81. he's had 13
heart attacks he drank and smoked for 35
years he smoked two packs a day for 35
years yeah 30 years until he had his
heart attack so the fact that he's still
here
Super Lucky of course I'm greedy I'd
love to see him go to 100 but have
perspective and you know I a long time
ago I realized when I would debate as an
atheist I was an atheist for 25 years
and then I eventually realized
hey pbd The Big Year Vision man the more
you need as much support as possible and
God's going to be your biggest support
when you're alone and nobody believes in
Your Vision you're going to need to talk
to somebody that's going to make sense
of this vision of yours you better get
close to the man upstairs so a lot of
things that I'm never going to have the
answer for
I have to rely on a source that's bigger
than me and that's the only thing I can
give my faith and comfort in I'm gonna
cry I'm gonna be in pain I'm going to be
emotional I'm going to have to go to a
lot of walks by myself and kind of break
down and go through it
but you know the the grace that he's
given me man I'm you have no idea how
big of a role that that the man upstairs
plays in my life so the reason why I'm
saying this is I fear those things are
going to happen but the way I know I'm
going to go through it is the One Source
this is the only way I can go through it
only way I can go through it if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop screaming check out our
politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell